una asonada golpista en desarrollo
dentro de otro golpe de estado el
autoproclamado líder de la nueva junta
gobernante de burkina faso y brahim
traoré marchó por las calles de la
capital
Este es un pueblo decidido un pueblo
Unido que ha resuelto tomar su destino
por sus propias manos eso es lo que
desde antes de ayer movilizó a los
jóvenes a los viejos a las mujeres a los
niños a salir a decidir no al régimen de
tamiba
la marcha se dio en el contexto de la
renuncia de Paul Henry santos
religiosos y comunitarios el militar
ofreció su dimisión este domingo para
evitar enfrentamientos con graves
consecuencias humanas y materiales este
hecho ratifica el poder de traer es un
joven que tiene la misma edad de Capitán
Thomas ankara nuestro expresidente y Hoy
estamos felices porque tenemos la
impresión de que le va a ir mejor que
los demás Así que pase lo que pase No
queremos nada más que Paz la inseguridad
en burkina faso termina aquí mismo en
este sentido la nueva junta militar
reiteró que se están apagando los focos
de desórdenes
queremos informar a la población que la
situación está bajo control y que poco a
poco estamos volviendo a la normalidad
las fuerzas de seguridad lanzaron gases
en lacrimógenos contra los manifestantes
que aún Se mantenían protestando de
manera violenta frente a la embajada de
Francia un grupo de burkineses acusó al
país europeo de apoyar a la hora ex
líder de amiba para un contragolpe a
ibra desde una de sus bases en el
territorio Francia mantiene sus tropas
asentadas en el país en el marco de la
operación Que lucha contra el yihadismo
extremo según la actual junta esta fue
una de las situaciones que Paul Henry
sandogo da viva supo manejar
[Aplausos]